[Music]
imagine this navigation your aircraft
has state-of-the-art avionics but your
map is from the 15th century command
please advise please advise
neuroscientists are stuck in this
harrowing predicament as they try to
make their way around the human brain
the first classical map made about a
century ago it is still widely used
today published in 1909 it defined
regions on the pinkish gray organ that
control our actions and functions the
fundamental unit of brain organization
for the cerebral cortex is what we call
a cortical area so on the map you could
say there's a country called speech and
under called short-term memory another
hand movement identifying every one of
these cortical areas became a major
objective of the human connectome
project the hcp leading the effort a
master map maker I consider myself a
cortical cartographer by July of last
year the HCP completed its first phase a
21st century world map of the brain we
reported the presence of 180 distinct
cortical areas 97 of them were new to
brain science the connectome gives us
this opportunity a really great tool to
be able to navigate the human brain
navigating the brain is more than just
naming cities and states you need to
understand the connections between them
the word connect home implies that the
fundamentally important thing about
brains is connections
this evening we'll be talking and
learning about two different kinds of
connections structural connections in
the brain versus functional connections
in the brain by structural connections
we're really talking about the physical
connections of wires that connect nerve
cells so structural connectivity looks
at the regions and the pathway is
connecting them the functional
connectivity though is more about how
different parts of the brain work
together on an ongoing basis brain
function arises from conversations that
different brain regions are having with
each other a functional map must track
living data conversations flowing
through the pathways between brain
regions we collected data from 1200
individuals we have them view different
tasks in the scanner things like a
memory tasks emotions on faces those
same regions of the brain seem to be
forming networks brain structure
is wired by its experience but we have
no idea in what form that wiring diagram
has that information and that's the big
puzzle to see how that translates into
individual nerve connections you need to
look much closer than David or Deanna's
technology can go down to the level of
individual neurons to quadrillion times
smaller what exactly is 2 quadrillion
times smaller well if the scale of
David's brain map is the big picture
probe on to it map of the whole earth
then the area that Jeff's covering would
be a city about the size of say
Sheboygan Wisconsin that little blur
that little blob there might be
Sheboygan or we're not sure that little
blob is a 1 millimeter cube of brain
tissue and it contains a staggering
number of neurons 50,000 nerve cells and
about 1 billion synapses so right now
there's no way to model an entire human
brain by diagramming its micro wiring
scientifically for now were lost in the
foggy limits of brain science it would
need more digital information than is
the actual digital content of the world
we are going to have the most wonderful
scientists in the world
talk to us about their experience with
mapping with map making with map
conceptualizing with with brain
understanding it's our first guest is a
professor of Neurobiology at Washington
University in st. Louis principal
investigator for the human connectome
project a fellow of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science he's internationally known for
his research on the structure functions
connectivity evolution and development
of cerebral cortex in humans and
non-human primates please welcome David
Van Essen
our next participant is a professor of
psychological and brain sciences at
Washington University st. Louis and an
investigator with the human connectome
project she's on the scientific board of
the brain and behavior Research
Foundation and the Stanley Foundation a
fellow of the Association for
psychological science and a member of
the American College of
neuropsychopharmacology please welcome
to Jana bartsch joining us is a
professor of molecular and cellular
biology and the Ramona Kahala professor
of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences at
Harvard University Development a
neurobiologist member of the National
Academy of Sciences Jeff Lichtman
our final guest is an associate
professor of psychology at Columbia
University and director of the
developmental affective neuroscience
laboratory she's a recipient of the
National Institute of Mental Health bio
behavioral research awards for
innovative new sciences the American
Psychological associations distinguished
scientific award for early career
contributions to psychology and the
developmental science early career
research a prize NIMH tottenham Jeff
what's the tank done well on this stage
you have four people who would probably
have slightly different ideas but what I
connect home is that so we like yeah so
from my perspective the connectome is a
project to map the connections between
nerve cells at synapses at the level of
synapses which is doable but the price
we pay is this extraordinary amount of
data we need so that doing a cubic
millimeter is for us a triumph and we're
not done with a cubic millimeter I
should say that's 2,000 terabytes of raw
data it's that's not a zip drive right
yeah but but in terms of the other
realms and maybe you guys can talk about
this cubic millimeter is your voxel size
that's the smallest leprosy name what do
you what do you how do you how would you
describe the connectome project is
someone who asks you you know so what do
you do at a party
well I think building on that answer
there's so many levels to address when
you're thinking about the connections in
the brain so there's the very very small
levels that have tremendous meaning and
contain an incredible amount of
information but then you can also look
at more macro levels that we can use
with fMRI that tell us about a different
level of representation of information
within the brain so it's going to take a
lot of data to be able to map out all of
those various levels and Deana well how
would you describe the Kinect um well so
I think I would agree with NIMH in the
sense that there's really connectomes at
many levels of analysis at the level
that Geoff is working on and then at the
level that says okay all those different
cubic millimeters in the brain how are
they wired up and how do they work
together and how do those conversations
to use a term that NIM used kind of
support all the different behaviors and
in thinking and emotions that humans are
able to do so I think we really need all
of those across all those scales
eventually to really understand the full
human connectome and and David would it
be fair to say that I deliberately left
you last hear that you're the most macro
here I think it's fair to say that
Deanna and NIM and I all work at the
very macroscopic level of the luxury of
working on the entire brain of living
individuals but we and the other part of
what drives us is the need for as not
only as much information as we can but
as rich across different types of
imaging magnetic resonance imaging is
the dominant one that we'll talk about
here but there are also other what we
call modalities magneto encephalography
electroencephalography give richer
information in the rapid time course of
the signals they follow but not as good
in the terms of the resolution in space
so all of these in types of information
can work hand in glove to give us deeper
insights into an incredibly challenging
and exciting set of problems yeah I mean
in many ways you're the the astronaut of
the suit
sort of untethered from the mothership
way out there what inspired you to do
the work that you do you know the
history neurobiology began with this guy
Karl who made this rather remarkable
leap of faith from looking at structure
that has more or less stood the test of
time this idea of a directional network
and I think just as going from Gregor
Mendel Mendel and his Peas to the atomic
structure of DNA to the human genome
going down and then back up again
I think neurobiology has to do the same
thing we have these ideas that now nerve
cells are connected in a wiring diagram
that's what qahal said and now what's up
to our generation and the generations
following to get those wiring diagrams
to really know what they are many people
would say the birth of neuroscience came
with the absolutely groundbreaking work
of Santiago Ramon Iike Hulk a Spanish
physician pathologist and ultimately
neuroscientist who used the technique
called the Golgi stain that allowed kaha
to stain brains in ways that very small
numbers of nerve cells would be rendered
dark and all the other cells would be
clear cahal was a gifted visual genius
he had inked paintbrush that's what he
did he just drew pictures on paper they
are absolutely beautiful
and not only beautiful but he inferred
this very dynamic view of the way
information flows there's a network of
cells and the cells are of various types
and they talk to each other and he was
right almost always and it was such a
radical idea that Golgi who invented the
stain absolutely did not believe that
that was true
[Music]
even at the Nobel Prize Golgi kept
saying that cahal was an idiot that he
just screwed this up entirely but time
has allowed him to win out here let's
see the tools that you use to get beyond
so the first thing we tried is to go if
the Golgi technique is good and every
small subset of cells are labeled black
and you can learn something about the
circuits what if we could see every
single cell and so instead of black we
made every cell a different color we
call this technique Brainbow and it's
been extraordinarily popular as
screensavers yeah so it's it's a very
powerful technique of labeling every
cell a different color and in certain
parts of the nervous system it really
does reveal circuits but when you get to
the cerebral cortex guess what there's
just so many wires there that you can't
actually tell the colors apart because
even at the finest level of resolution
of the light microscope there's a
picture of those bigger blobs or nerve
cells and all that stuff in between that
felt work are the gazillion wires that
attach them and and you can't resolve
them as individuals so yeah we have to
go to a different technique so that's
plan a so now Plan B is what we're
working on now which is to do this not
with light and color but use electrons
which have a much shorter wavelength and
us the ability to resolve every one of
these wires and the way we do this is we
take a block of brain and we fill it
with a metal called osmium and we take
that block of brain filled with osmium
that little black spot in there and then
we put it in a plastic very hard plastic
and we put it on a chuck and we move it
up and down against a diamond knife
that's what's going on in that a second
picture and then from there out comes
one section after another they're about
a thousandth as thick as a human hair so
we get a thousand per hair thickness and
then we pick them up on a tape and then
we take a picture of each and every one
of them with a very high resolution
microscope and the pictures are 250,000
pixels by 250,000 pixels each image and
then we have to take 33333 sections like
that to do a cubic millimeter so that's
so you take that level of resolution in
2d and do 33333 to make it 3d right so
it's basically a filmstrip and you take
those pictures and you stack them up and
you get a stack of images that are now a
three-dimensional version of the brain
and then you color in the objects using
deep convolutional neural Nets to
generate the structures in the brain
here is a dendrite of a nerve cell and
an axon yeah to that cell in green and
and that's one little piece of an area
that we did that is just so discouraging
it's so depressing there's just so much
stuff in these brains it there's 1,500
nerve cells this is three billionths of
a mouse brain three bill it took us five
years to do three billions of a mouse
brain when we started it's just
extraordinary in a synapse every cubic
micron so they're 1,500 synapses in
there yeah
I mean you know I can say this to all
four of you but my really my response is
just I am not worthy I mean do you ever
think about how you know 50 years from
now a hundred years from now they will
look back on this work and that's
primitive and stupid it no they would
it's like the early days of genomics
when people actually use their thumbs
and pipette men to get the DNA sequence
of a virus and now we have these robots
who can do a whole genome in a day or
two for a few thousand dollars we are
now back at the virus stage we're just
starting NIM whoo where would you say in
terms of the two parts that we're going
to be discussing functional and
structural sort of aspects of the macro
brain where are the scientific
disagreements within that where what are
the what are the arguments what are the
big questions yeah I mean I think when
just looking at the people that we have
on the panel here one question that we
want to know is are the are the data
that we're getting at the level that
Jeff's seeing comparable to the types of
level that we're getting with fMRI and
what is fMRI measuring what does it
stand for fMRI functional magnetic
resonance imaging so in what's I
thinking a picture of it's the data that
gives you the activation patterns on the
brain so what we commonly think of as
the blobs on the brain and is that the
pictures of the neuron electricity so
it's not electricity it is an area of
active inquiry to try and understand
what is the bold signals so when you're
seeing those colored pictures what
you're getting is a statistical map of a
signal called bold which is giving us an
index of where oxygen is being
distributed differentially across the
brain as that the brain is engaging in a
particular task so it's
it's data that presumes that a mapping
of blood activity and oxygenated blood
activity in the brain is comparable to
neuronal and cognitive them even AI
cognitive that's too much to say but
electro chemical activity in the brain
is that fair to say right it's an
inference we can only make an inference
with those data how good is that
inference the challenge is in one little
blob of the fMRI image you have fifty
thousand nerve cells and a billion
synapses from hundreds of different cell
types over many different layers of
cerebral cortex each part of the
cerebral cortex is layered and there are
different kinds of things going on in
each layer and all that is compacted
into a single dot and underneath bye-bye
yes so it is a global average you know I
would say if you try to do the
equivalent of an fMRI on the United
States you would be looking at energy
use in cities perhaps and you would
Logan yes Sheboygan a tracking you might
be able to get a little bit of Sheboygan
data you'd get more data from bigger
cities and these cities have a lot of
energy use in the daytime they fall off
at night but it's not like nothing is
going on but but you would not be
looking at each individual person or
each individual activity you would be
looking at you know essentially all the
lights on in a particular part of the
brain at a particular time and so you
can infer something I'm not saying you
can't infer something but there is still
a chasm I think between the machine
that's doing the work which is very very
intricate and these rather global
macroscopic techniques that can work in
a living human brain i if if you want me
to do this to your brain I have to kill
you so I'm scared of you most of all
that's for sure Deanna fMRI useful tool
but there's a huge horizon beyond it
that's her to say yes and and David you
would go along with that we don't need
to belabor this point I also agree
strongly and I would point out that
there's another type of information that
is very important for the human
connectome project and other endeavors
which is we call diffusion imaging and
looking at structural connectivity and
that is also a very informative method
it relies on the preferred diffusion of
water along of the length of axons
within the white batter is a little bit
faster than trying to get across the
membranes of each axon that indirectly
informs us about local orientations of
fiber bundles that can then be stitched
together to estimate long distance
connections from one region no gray
matter to another that is also fraught
with its own challenges because it's
looking at bundles that are Criss
crossing one another to reflect the
actual reality of brain circuitry and we
can make estimates but they're not
perfect and so on another the hot
debates in the field is what can we
infer that we can put confidence in and
what do we have to be very careful of
and not over interpret but I have to say
david those are some damn pretty
pictures is great why spend so much time
and money mapping every single
connection if we might never be able to
finish it yeah you know there was a I
think everyone probably would agree that
the human genome project was worthwhile
this was a descriptive attempt to get
the nucleotide sequence down to every
single nucleotide in the DNA of a human
being and when that project was first
proposed there were a lot of people said
why should we spend all this money to
get all this DNA we know a lot of it is
junk DNA there's a lot of things in
there we don't care about why do this
this is just going to be impossible to
understand but no one in the scientific
community at least Dow
it's the extraordinary value of actually
having a data set that describes the
entire human genome and not only that
now that we have the way to do it we can
get your genome and my genome and
they're different and the genome of
people who have diseases are a little
different a profound amount of insight
has come from generating that data set
and I see connectomics just like I see
genomics it is a way to describe the
brain at enough resolution that we can
begin to make reasonable hypotheses
about how brains of people who have
disease are different from brains of
people who don't have diseases of the
brain for example how baby brains are
wired differently than adult brains and
old people even old people who don't
have dementia and my children would
count me in this category are a little
different from young people we're a
little more set in our ways why is that
where does that change take place where
all our memories stored there are
millions and millions of questions I
think where this kind of data would be
justified by analogy to the genome since
you were talking about that just a
moment ago how much individual
variability do you expect in the
connectome does that question make sense
yes that's a great question all right
obviously there are five of us sitting
here and we all have an entirely
different set of experiences that have
molded us into the adults we are people
like me believe that information is
embedded in our wiring diagrams so it
would be shocking if our wiring diagrams
are very similar now
it's true also that genomes are not
identical otherwise we would all look
the same which would be scary I think
but there's no way in which the
connectome variability would be on the
order of chimps have 99% of the same
genetic information it may be peers that
humans do I think this is a good
question it may be depending on what
level of resolution you look at if you
look at the major pathways that connect
parts of the brain things that come out
of the bold technique
and perhaps at a diffusion tensor
imaging you might find that brains are
95% similar I actually don't know but it
probably they're quite similar if you
get down to the wiring of a little piece
of cerebral cortex my guess is that you
will find substantial differences
between the brains of different people
yeah I was gonna say I mean it's it's
kind of the glass half empty glass half
full and I think this is one of the
really interesting things that's coming
out of the data produced by the human
connectome project cuz one of our
explicit goals was to look at individual
differences in brains and relate them to
behavior and I think we're seeing
exactly that that there is remarkable
similarity in the sort of basic network
structure at the level of sheboygan and
you know in Chicago and New York but
there are also really interesting
individual differences that seem to
relate to behavior including a lot of
those sort of high-level cognitive and
emotional and you know in motivational
behaviors so I think we're gonna see
it's both that there's real commonality
in key structures but really important
individual differences that link to
behavior I think many people use this as
a strong argument against doing this
well if everybody's brain is different
what are you gonna learn by doing one
brain and it would be like saying what
could you learn about if every city is
different if a why teach all the kids
right yeah there's another example but
you know every city is different but if
you studied in detail Paris
I suspect you would get insights that
would translate to London and to New
York David who inspired you to do this
work and what was your original
conception of a brain map I've been
fascinated by this regal cortex for 40
years and when I first started working
on the problem I was looking at the
visual cortex of an animal model the
macaque monkey it has a sheet of tissue
that is convoluted to get it to fit
inside the skull of a monkey and one of
the challenges I faced was that in order
to get information
about the brain and and the connections
it was necessary to take slices of the
brain and look one slice at a time I was
compelled by the analogy with maps of
the earth that two dimensional maps of
convoluted xi are very informative so at
that time I actually used pencil and
tracing paper to make crude but useful
maps of the visual cortex and then the
entire cerebral cortex of the macaque
monkey I knew this was a job better
suited for a computer and when I moved
to Caltech in 1976 we started working on
that problem but it literally took two
decades to get the computer horsepower
but more importantly the algorithms into
operational shell-shaped for others to
lead the way a number of groups have
worked on that effort so now we can make
computerized maps of the the monkey
cerebral cortex but more excitingly of
the human cerebral cortex which is even
more complicated and convoluted when you
were kicking around back as a you know
advanced science student in high school
and maybe college what were the visuals
that you could see that would would show
you what the map of the braid or the
functionality of the brain supposedly
was all about they were pictures and
books and it's nice that you've brought
forward exhibit a which is the classic a
century-old map of the human cerebral
cortex by the great German anatomist
Corbin Ian Rodman this is the 1909 map
you were talking about exactly right I
learned about it in college and it's
still taught today as one representation
but it's analogous to maps of the
Earth's surface from the mid 16th
century for instance which were quaint
and colorful
Broadman there's a colored version of
his this is the map that he used and it
was actually accurate to this day for a
few of the 50 regions that he identified
but there was reason to suspect that
this was not the whole story and it's
been a century long endeavor to make
better maps of the human cerebral cortex
the Rendon felled the room there
laterally non median hemisphere -
Dominguez your German is impeccable
[Music]
middle lung 1907 so getting from these
maps you had to and you alluded to it a
moment ago really begin to describe the
meaning of the folds in the brain right
that's correct I think of the folds of
the human cerebral cortex as analogous
to the crumpling of the Earth's surface
into mountains and valleys and other
geographic features and that's of course
very important as part of the physical
substrate for understanding the lay of
the land quite literally the the
cerebral cortex contains about 16
billion neurons in each individual and
it's the interaction and communications
the local and long-distance connections
and functions of those neurons that
determine what we call the parcels or
the cortical areas in the human cortical
stone sheet so is it the case that in
the beginning the brain is smooth in an
embryo and redevelopment and even into
the the first two trimesters of human
embryonic fetal development it's very
smooth just gets slightly curved in a
shape alright so this is first trimester
right yes I think so go no real cream so
by this by the beginning of the second
trimester things have gotten into you
know somewhat curves shape but in the
explosion of cortical growth in the last
the third trimester of human gestation
things get really wild and like goes up
like that yours is good for one
individual and mine is even more
crumpled so it's pretty severe yes
so like and so Biden there are this the
more of this well the more that can fit
inside the the skull that has to get
through
birth canal that's one of the reasons
why we have have to have a highly
convoluted cortex to get a pizza like
sheet of tissue for each hemisphere
crumpled up to fit inside a compact
skull that can get through the birth
canal but by birth the cortical
convolutions are nearly as complex as
they are in an adult even though the
brain is only one-third the size of an
adult brain it only goes to show how
important the brain is in terms of
creating more complexity in a confined
space right you're limited in the space
you're unlimited in the level of
complexity that you can do there are
other limitations but this is how the
brain solves its own sort of problem of
dynamics NIM
would you say that the maps that we have
now the visual sort of tools that we
have now are helping us to pose new
questions or answer more questions than
they pose both for sure I mean I think
that as a developmental psychologist the
reason why I came into this is because I
was very interested in behavior and
where behavior comes from and being able
to get some tool that gives us structure
and function to attach these behaviors
to changes everything
it starts to answer the question that
you raised which is how does the
environment get under the skin so to
speak right so to use an analogy from
the heart our cardiac tissue is the
tissue and our heartbeat is the behavior
that's associated with that tissue so
likewise our brain is the tissue and
behavior is the output of that tissue so
if you want to understand and be able to
ask deeper questions about behaviors and
where they come from and why am i
different from you and why are we
similar in other ways then being able to
have this tool changes the game Deana
can
can you explain for us the great
pictures that we have of the twin
identical twin brains these are
identical twins well I think that the
twin data actually does a wonderful job
of illustrating what NIM talked about in
terms of both how the environment gets
into the brain and how genetics shaped
the brain so when you look at the brains
of twins there are things especially
identical twins who share the vast
majority 99% of their genetic makeup
there are clear similarities things that
are more similar about those twins and
other ones but there are also
fascinating differences then they don't
look identical I mean I know it's not a
word I would even know because there are
also environmental factors that get
under the skin and into the brain that
are going to shape you know how the
brain wires up how those convolutions
are created over time how and the twins
behavior will probably follow and be
similarly different or the same
depending on how much they've
experienced the environment differently
and even if you take identical twins
they'd only would actually do this and
put them in identical green rooms and
fed them identical green food and gave
them identical glasses of water at the
exact same time every day for eight
years you would still get differences
you would get some differences for sure
yeah but it would be less it might be I
mean that's actually a great question we
know it's not a good experiment you know
but I think you know obviously the to
the degree that we believe environment
also shapes brain development the more
similar the environment the more likely
it is that you know those are going to
be shaped in a similar way but again we
can't really do that experiment to
deliberately manipulate how similar are
not similar the environments are David
but since most of the cortical folding
the development of the convolutions
occurs before birth that's actually
occurring in not quite identical but in
the same
and very similar environmental
influences so the fact that the outcome
have at birth of new born identical
twins their brains are very different
that tells us that a lot of this is
driven by subtle perhaps epigenetic
influences but and perhaps small
differences in environment lead to
perturbations that lead to different
folding outcomes but the other part of
what's important I think here is that
even though the the newborn twins or any
individual has a relatively highly
convoluted and relatively mature looking
cortex
during the expansion that occurs by a
factor of three especially in early
after birth postnatal development the
regions that change the most are the
regions that we associated with higher
cognitive functions so that's where our
plasticity our ability to learn and
develop and emerge with sophisticated
concepts like drive this conversation
that's occurring in specialized region
of cortex that are more plastic they are
also more vulnerable to abnormal
experience and perturbed development so
this relationship to disorders and
disease comes into play in that regard
as well during this rapid period things
such as the autism spectrum might emerge
if because it is such a complement it
complicated and rapid developmental
period debt is not well understood
physiologically that's correct although
we also know that there is a genetic
component of heritability to autism in
terms of the likelihood of having an
individual a child somewhere on that
autism spectrum disorder but it's called
a spectrum from good for good reason
because there's tremendous diversity in
many ways and that's where the
experience particularly in early
childhood development is likely to shape
the trajectory of ended
Jules and where we desperately want to
understand how can we decipher what's
going on and perhaps better treat and
modify the outcome name can you describe
let's extend this developmental
discussion because a clock begins as
David was sort of saying at birth and
there are various kinds of developmental
pathways that are that are emerging at
different times and we've started to
separate them a little bit and and
really understand what race takes place
at what time yes
so human brain development is one of the
most fascinating things right because we
start off all of us as a single-celled
organism and then we all go through this
miracle of development where we create
the most complex 3 pounds in the
universe and we all do it more or less
the same and yet we all have beautiful
individual differences so where do those
come from so why would Mother Nature go
through that whole process because
that's really inefficient metabolically
that's incredibly arguably and efficient
and the reason is because that gives us
what David referred to earlier of this
incredible plasticity during development
so it's like throwing a big fishing net
out into the ocean and then pulling back
what you need because when we're new on
this planet when we just land on this
planet we don't know what household
we're gonna land in we don't know what
the climates going to be we don't know
what the languages that we're going to
have to learn and yet we all do it and
so in many ways in order to understand
the mature human brain you want to
understand brain during infancy and
childhood because that's what gives us
that end product we're all exquisitely
adapted to our environments in which our
brains grow up but the profile of the
adaptation process the becoming an adult
the maturation the development of
personality etc is actually a
subtractive process
it's a series of progressive and
subtractive or regressive processes so
if we look in the back of the brain
where the visual cortex is you see this
overshoot that I described and then this
pruning away like you prune your rose
bushes pruning away of the synapses that
you your brain learns it doesn't need
it's efficient grat what what are what
are the two functions here that are
being looked at so in the in the pinkish
line we're looking in the back of the
brain and the visual cortex and you see
that initial increase in synaptic
density of the density of the
connections and then you get this
pruning back as we get older and then if
you look at that blue line that's the
frontal cortex and in the front of the
brain and it does the same thing but you
can see that the whole curve is shifted
over so that's reflecting that we have
these processes of increase in synapses
and regression that's happening in our
brain but in a hierarchical fashion
where we go from the back of the brain
to the front of the brain which really
reflects the way that these behaviors
emerge over development right Ken yeah
does this mean that evolutionarily
cognitively we require visual
information to inform our cognitive
selves and so that's why cognitive
development might lag behind visual
right so brain development makes sense
evolutionarily but also within one
individual's lifetime so first you have
your sensory systems coming online
because you need to be able to take in
information from the environment then
you've got motor systems to allow you to
interact with the environment and those
are necessary prerequisites in order to
do all of the cool higher-level stuff
that we can do like plan for the future
or fall in love or regulate our emotions
or even be blind I mean blind people are
going through an adaptive process right
so we have multiple sensory systems
right so we have this plasticity early
in life where we can shift resources
where it suits us best how does learning
multiple languages early on affect brain
development any knowledge about that
yeah there's a lot of excitement in this
area so one is just speaks to the
behavior of language right so your brain
will undergo neural Darwinism during
development it learns based on who's
being activated which synapses are being
activated or not if they're being
activated then I'm going to keep them
and if they're not then I'm gonna prune
them away so if I'm being exposed to
both English and Japanese as a six month
old then my brain is going to hang on to
both of those that was your experience
your experience that was not I know I
don't speak Japanese
I wish that in and of itself is amazing
that we're that plastic right so so I
can't speak Japanese there are many
sounds phonemes within Japanese that I
will never be able to process but when I
was five months old I could but my brain
decided it didn't need to hang on to
those anymore so that in and of itself
is amazing and then the second thing is
there are all these cascading functions
though all these cascading benefits that
you get so children who can speak to
language to languages fluently also have
this amazing benefit in their prefrontal
cortex so they're able to switch very
easily in terms of cognitive functions
because they've had a lifetime of
switching what languages they're
speaking and understanding what the
other person is expecting of them and
I've also have also heard and this is
somebody from South Asia who spoke I
think seven languages her experience was
that once you get past two three four
and five or easy there's a brain is that
what is that what the brain tells you
right so the brain starts picking up on
what are the common principles that I
need to extract from a language and so
as you gather I guess three four if
that's the magic number then you get a
broader sense of what are the
generalized principles here that you can
apply to new languages so yeah I would
say probably the sec
language is the hardest to learn and
after that it's like beasting John one
thing that's important about that too is
those effects don't just last through
childhood there's evidence that they
last your entire life and actually may
be protective later in life against
things like cognitive decline and even
dementia more work is needed there but
there's a lot of evidence that they have
very beneficial long-lasting effects
it's freewill and illusion in other
words is our brain the be-all and and
now that's the sophisticated the be-all
and end-all to our decision-making when
you get to the connectome will you be
looking at a deterministic image anybody
want to take that on
I would like to because the one of the
great surprises for me when we began
actually reconstructing brains at the
level of resolution of the wiring
diagram is the insane density of wires
and synapses in the brain and it might
as well be called free will because it
is so darn complicated and so it's not
that you have to find that one place
where there's a switch that you're going
to throw dice and you're gonna go left
or right the whole brain is made up of
you know billions of elements trillions
of synapses actually that each have a
certain amount of stochastic behavior so
you might as well call this freewill
it's it is freewill for us we believe we
have freewill if you look down from an
airplane at the New York City at night
you'll see most people on the highways
are leaving the city
you look early in the morning most
people are coming in that doesn't seem
like freewill to somebody up there it
seems very much like we're doing exactly
what we're supposed to do to make the
city work
anybody else stuff is hanging on
freewill I agree with Jeff it is just
it's in our control what does control
mean that's part of what we want to
decipher will we ever understand it
perhaps not but fundamentally the
richness of brain circuitry gives us in
practical terms the free will that is
handle on that concept do you believe
brain data including but not limited to
the connectome can be faithfully
recreated in a von Neumann machine von
Neumann machine is something like a
Turing machine a theoretical idea of a
computer that would reach a level of
complexity that would begin to that
would begin to behave comparably to what
we think of as autonomous I get this
question a lot that if you get the
wiring diagram aren't you 90% of the way
there to having a thinking machine the
wiring diagram is a static entity at the
moment you take it and it doesn't tell
you the way information is flowing
through those wires this was one of the
great discoveries of neurobiology this
idea that information flows in a
directional way through individual nerve
cells that information is often
stimulated by things from the outside
that are activating your retina or the
cells in your ear or your skin and none
of that is built into these wiring
diagrams that's coming from the outside
and so we don't when we look at the
wiring diagram we don't see what is
actually going on at the level of fMRI
at least you see areas of the brain
lighting up but at this fine level of
the way the machine works we're far from
having a way of putting information into
those wires in a way that simulates the
way actual experience goes into the
brain David you're gonna say something
do you remember what it was a follow-up
to the question about autonomous agents
and not artificial intelligence and one
thing I've learned from my over my
scientific career is
never say never to and earnestly because
some of the things that we're talking
about is everyday scientific experiences
were out of the realm of what I could
even imagine let alone say that would be
possible someday so technology advances
are driven by the laws of physics but
they can make profound advances so some
of what we were talking about up here
right now were impossible to imagine
when you were an undergraduate that's
that is correct even magnetic resonance
imaging
I remember thinking about would there be
some way to measure brain activity and
talking to experts and it didn't seem
like it was going to go anywhere in the
early 1980s that was lack of vision and
insight about how the clever ways into
that new technologies could be achieved
by physicists and engineers but I was
also going to come back to the point
about artificial intelligence and many
people know about entities like Watson
and other extraordinarily sophisticated
computers which in some contexts can do
impressively well in communicating with
humans and giving the appearance of
intelligent thought and arguably there
is some degree of intelligence there
I don't think Watson now would be able
to sit at this with a fifth chair or six
chair and carry his or her digital
weight in this kind of free-flowing
conversation but I heard I heard Watson
described one time as a combination of
the Library of Congress and sprinter
Usain Bolt running around getting right
source material working in a profoundly
different way so will there be versions
of artificial intelligence in the future
that are dramatically better than Watson
unquestionably in my mind will that ever
approach the cleverness and insight and
perspective of real human being
having a conversation like this I
personally am on The Skeptical side
I wouldn't say impossible but I'm
doubtful and I think if they are doing
it one of the fascinating challenges is
to what degree will computers emulate
human-like thought strategies to what
extent will they use principles of
neural circuitry like Jeff focuses on to
process information in ways that emulate
the characteristics that Deanna nem and
I would look at in the living human
brain a huge open and exciting question
and it'll be up for the next generation
of young scientists to carry that ball
forward how can we continue to develop
new synaptic responses as an adult yeah
that's the kind of you know Jack LaLanne
question yeah so we we do we are I mean
the fact that we can learn new things
the fact that we can form new memories
depends on these micro structural
changes happening otherwise we would
have no memory so we have incredible
plasticity early in life it decreases
but it never goes away permanently and
some argue that in some areas of the
prefrontal cortex we actually never
reach our full mature state because
we're constantly exhibiting high levels
of plasticity so and some of the
exciting interventions are things like
how can exercise boost that even further
for individuals who are experiencing
cognitive decline or how can certain
pharmacologic agents boost that
plasticity further career changing
millennial career changing one is sleep
it's that all the things that we know
are good for us are probably having an
effect on increasing our plasticity yeah
yeah I was just gonna comment on that
that you know sleep and you know there's
fascinating theories about how sleep is
a way to sort of clean up synapses so
that you can do more the next day you
know there's fascinating work looking at
brain injury in ways that rehabilitation
can help with you know rewiring the
brain
so I think there's a lot of hope that it
will continue on it's it's less but it
still continues yeah well you know what
I hate to say this because it's a downer
but being an old person and I'd like to
think that I'm infinitely flexible but I
remember when I was young being
impressed that how narrow-minded my
parents were when they were my age and I
have a feeling my children think a
little bit about me this way so although
I feel a plastic I think the world is
beginning to assume I just always talk
about the same thing over and over that
I say it's because it's really
interesting but it's probably because
all the other things my circuits could
have done have been pruned away rust all
we are is rust but I mean if you took up
the violin or something or you know
wouldn't you
[Laughter]
I'm so glad I didn't end on Jeff David
well I see a lot of younger faces out in
the audience and would reiterate the
point that you guys are the future those
of us who are above 50 to put it mildly
you know we will continue to work hard
and look for opportunities to strengthen
in plasticity in healthy aging we will
continue to chip away at the profound
impact of brain disorders and diseases
which is a scourge of society and we
desperately need better solutions and we
are excited by the interest in in the
brain in neuroscience that's a
manifested by the wonderful attendance
at this session and we look forward to
future years in reading and learning
about the accomplishment of the next
generation so thanks to all
[Applause]
[Music]
you